[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 19 mai bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction de tv 78 voici
les titres de l'actualité locale
c'est une conséquence malheureuse de la
crise épidémique les dons en faveur des
associations diminue à l'image de la
ligue contre le cancer
son président national redoutent une
disparition de plusieurs comités
départementaux qu'en est il pour
l'antenne des yvelines interview à
suivre avec l'interdiction de circuler à
plus de 100 kilomètres de son domicile
des solutions alternatives émergent en
vue d pont de l'ascension et de la
pentecôte et les franciliens à yvelinois
se tourner davantage vers le tourisme
local
exemple dans ce journal à chevreuse ou
les réservations de gîtes ont explosé
enfin il se prépare en vue de la
réouverture le 30 mai le domaine de
dampierre en yvelines a été autorisée
par la préfecture à accueillir à nouveau
du public pour ce faire des mesures
sanitaires mises en place et des
activités repensé reportage
mais avant de développer ces titres le
feu vert du conseil scientifique pour le
second tour des élections municipales le
28 juin il a remis ce mardi son rapport
au gouvernement pour l'organisation du
scrutin dont la campagne électorale
devrait être cependant modifié en raison
du contexte sanitaire edouard philippe
demandera également un deuxième rapport
15 jours avant la date du second tour le
premier ministre qui selon les
informations de plusieurs de nos
confrères s'apprêtent à déclencher un
débat parlementaire suivi d'un vote
l'exécutif souhaite que toutes les
forces politiques prennent publiquement
position sur le sujet et dans les
yvelines les électeurs de 44 communes
devront se présenter à nouveau aux urnes
pour élire leurs maires et leurs
conseillers municipaux dans l'actualité
également cette ordonnance du conseil
d'état le gouvernement va devoir lever
l'interdiction des réunions dans les
lieux de culte dans un délai de 8 jours
l'institution estime que cette décision
mise en place avec l'état d'urgence
sanitaire était disproportionnée qu'elle
portait atteinte à la liberté de culte
le décret pris le 11 mai
estrun tout rassemblement au sein des
établissements de culte à l'exception et
des cérémonies funéraires limité à 20
personnes
le conseil d'état estime que des mesures
d'encadrement moins stricts peuvent être
prises quelle réaction du côté de la
communauté juive de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les propos
sont recueillis par wilfrid richy ce
temps que je n'ai pas l'assurance que ça
peut se faire en toute sécurité
je ne tiens pas rouvrir c'est à dire que
le conseil d'état a le conseil d'état
revient sur un sur une demande du
gouvernement se met maintenant est-ce
que ce qu'est ce qu'elle est le point de
vue des scientifiques du personnel
médical est ce qu'il est vraiment temps
d'ouvrir un doublé ses lieux de culte
pour que pour que les fidèles puissent
revenir en toute sécurité sans essence
infecter d'autres ou à voir on va voir
des personnes malades dans nos murs la
pratique du culte on la continue puisque
chacun l'affiché soit dès qu'ils ont des
questions de vue et des fidèles peuvent
m'appeler me demander de renseignement
des informations donc pour l'instant est
rond continuer à se faire alors bien sûr
chacun chez soi avec la règle des 100 km
de déplacements autorisés instaurée par
le gouvernement pour limiter la
propagation du coronavirus les
franciliens restent dans leur région
mais pour profiter du beau temps et
s'évader en pleine nature avec les pont
de l'ascension et de la pentecôte qui
arrivent beaucoup se tournent vers la
vallée de chevreuse et les gîtes de
france ont pris d'assaut reportage dans
l'un d'entre eux avec marylène iapichino
et patrick jacques de dixmude la vallée
de chevreuse ces villages de charme et
ses nombreux sites aux verts sont les
grands gagnants de la restriction de
déplacement à 100 kilomètres de son
domicile
après la vague d'annulations à l'annonce
du confinement et deux mois blanc céline
zaidi a retrouvé le sourire et une
clientèle al'annonce du déconfinement ça
a été dans le sens inverse où on est une
demande énorme
j'irai rarement entre téléphone mail
réservation en ligne
là on est totalement débordé entre
mi-mai on va dire du d'une demi merde au
31 mai alors il a fallu s'organiser les
heures de battement entre deux
réservations sont rallongés pour laisser
du temps pour le nettoyage et l'aération
de logements l'équipe va jusqu'à faire
bouillir le linge de maison à 90 degrés
chaque jt doter de solutions
hydro alcoolique après les clients qui
sont venus jusque là arrivés avec leurs
masques pour se protéger une fois qu'ils
sont installés on les voit un petit peu
plus détendus ils ont plus de masques
mais ils sont vraiment ils sont vraiment
gentils parce qu'il ya une certaine
règle des distances
il n'y a rien à dire ça ça se passe très
très bien une clientèle nouvelle
habituellement d'affaires ou étrangère
elle a été remplacée par des familles
essentiellement parisienne mais si le
mois de mai affiche complet
l'incertitude demeure pour la suite
la propriétaire attend les prochaines
annonces gouvernementales
dès que le président parle on a tout de
suite les appels ou les annulations
commande ou annulation en fonction de ce
qui est annoncé
c'est vraiment flagrant pour le mois de
juin les quatre gîtes indépendants n'ont
que 10 % de réservations
la saison d'été semble être guidé par le
maintien de la restriction des 100 km ou
non et nous retournerons en fin de
journal en vallée de chevreuse dans les
jardins d'un ancien domaine royal rester
avec nous cet incendie à présent à
sartrouville la salle de gymnastique
annexe du gymnase romain rolland a été
entièrement détruite par les flammes
cette nuit l'alerté a été donnée aux
alentours de 3 heures du matin l
intervention de trente deux sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines a permis à
d'épargné le reste de la structure
aucun blessé n'est à déplorer les quatre
occupants du site ayant été évacués un
incendie d'origine criminelle un engin
incendiaire a été retrouvé sur place un
mineur de 15 ans a été interpellé
l'enquêté confiée à la sûreté urbaine de
sartrouville les dons ne baisse pas mais
il s'effondre voici le message alarmant
d'axel kahn président de la ligue contre
le cancer dans les colonnes du jdd ce
dimanche
l association de lutte contre le cancer
redoutent la disparition de certains de
ses comités départementaux comme
conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire
bonsoir maurice brun en soit vous êtes
le président du comité des yvelines de
la ligue contre le cancer ce constat de
baisse des dons en faveur de
l'association dont parle
axel kahn est ce que il s'est observé
aussi au niveau local dans le
département des yvelines alors il faut
être honnête et dire que ce n'est pas
complètement le cas
ce n'est pas complètement comme non pas
parce que nous avons effectivement pu
faire des mesures mais tout simplement
parce que nous avons un énorme retard de
courrier qui nous a été livrée que en
milieu de semaine donc fin de semaine
dernière et que nous avons nous avons
d'abord suite au déconfinement aurait
ouvert nos locaux que lundi dernier ont
pas hier mais le onze bien évidemment et
que à la suite de ça nous avons d'abord
satisfait les besoins immédiats qui nous
ont été demandées par notamment nos
donateurs qui ont plusieurs général
cette période ont tendance à perdre un
petit peu l'horreur reçu fiscal qui leur
est nécessaire pour la prochaine
déclaration des impôts dont on a déjà eu
beaucoup de travail à réaliser un centre
d'affaires de ce genre et ne l'ont pas
encore pu dépouiller les courriers que
nous avons reçus pendant cette période
dont je ne pourrais pas dire évidemment
qu'il en soit ainsi mais mais il est
évident entier que le le centre des
attentions de tous les donateurs a été
évidemment en ans et deux mois et demi
largement tournée vers d'autres d'autres
urgences et ceux qui ça se comprend tout
à fait bien simplement simplement c'est
vrai que il faut rappeler en premier
c'est que la ligue contre le cancer est
fondée et subventionné en totalité par
les dons du public
nous recevons que 2 ou 3 % de
subventions d'état sur des projets
particuliers donc nous dépendons
entièrement de la gentillesse et de la
delà de l'action de nos bénévoles auprès
des auprès des donateurs et deuxièmement
si vous voulez le le nous n'avons pas
l'expérience de ce genre de personne n'a
l'expérience d'ailleurs de ce genre de
situation nous les conséquences pardon
vous les connaîtrez dans l'est dans les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
dans une dizaine de jours ressemblement
est donc la raison
oui alesis disons qu effectivement après
j'ai deux années trois années
successives où il ya eu là le changement
de dispositions concernant les les ailes
et l'impôt sur la fortune
ensuite il ya eu le gilet jaune et
ensuite tout ya maintenant ceux des
confinement si tout était très
déstabilisé ces dernières années et
c'est difficile pour nous de faire gaffe
allemands ni un pronostic ni un bilan
viennent donc pas possible encore de
savoir s'il ya risque ou pas pour le
comité départemental excellent thème
parle de risque pour plusieurs comités
locaux départementaux de la ligue contre
le cancer en france
alors je pense quand même qu'on peut
s'en faire preuve de trop de d'audace
dire que ce ne sera pas le cas du comité
sont 18 parce que nous sommes dans un
van ly comité relativement bien doté et
deuxièmement nous avons un socle de
donateurs importants qui a évidemment
pas mal fondu depuis quelques années
mais qui reste qu'un important et puis
troisièmement nous avons immédiatement
dès le début du confinement mis en
chômage partiel
la totalité nos salariés pour éviter
justement là bas le maximum de pression
pendant cette période de deuil de 10
l'action
un rappel pour ceux qui nous regardent
pourquoi ces dons sont ils primordiaux
pour la lutte contre le cancer à quoi
finalement certes il a financé ces dons
eh bien écoutez si vous voulez nous
dépenser en environ trois gâteaux si
j'ose dire
la plus grosse part va à l'aide aux
personnes malades
l'organisation de fin de support comme
on dit les visites dans les hôpitaux les
tout ce qu'on peut organiser pour faire
mieux supporter le cancer à ceux qui en
sont touchées
le deuxième gros poste c'est évidemment
la recherche qui effectivement elle est
est primordial c'est véritablement
l'investissement pour l'avenir et le
troisième poste et la prévention
donc si vous voulez là on a à la fois
bien sûr une perte une chute dans nos
dépenses non là aussi quelques dépenses
en moins donc si on laissait cette
balance entre les deux qui devront
permettre de dire quel est l'état de la
situation et vous évoquez la recherche
il serait dommageable d'arrêter ses dons
pour la recherche la recherche contre le
cancer tue ne cesse de progresser
bien évidemment l'espoir de tous les
gens surtout ceux qui sont touchés par
le cancer c'est bien évidemment les
progrès de la recherche médicale
et cela c'est absolument primordiale je
le sais que c'est absolument
indispensable dans l'esprit de nos
donateurs et pour nous c'est un
investissement d'avenir sur lequel on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas faire la passe
une dernière question à maurice mans est
ce que vous redoutez une autre crise due
aux effets secondaires de cette crise
sanitaire le fait aussi que pendant
cette période
des personnes non moins bien fait
soigner d'autres maladies comme le
cancer est ce que vous redoutez qui est
une conséquence à plus long terme
alors il est fait qu'un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux ont un petit peu écarté gip a
écarté volontairement mais n'ont pas
rendu les choses les plus faciles
concernant les personnes touchées par le
cancer qui ne peut-être n'ont pas pu
avoir accès à leur jeter mios qui ont
peut-être eux-mêmes n'ont pas souhaité
aller voir leur médecin qui ne se sont
pas fait diagnostiquer pour laquelle
n'ont pas fait les actions de prévention
il ira vrai seulement des retombées je
sais trop si c'est à dire des c vrai qu
effectivement en tout état de cause s'il
coronavirus a engendré depuis une
trentaine de milliers de décès en gros
jusqu'à présent c'est le cinquième de
tous les décès qui sont enregistrés
chaque année en france par le cancer
merci maurice brun d'avoir été avec nous
et merci bien
mais je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du comité des yvelines de la
ligue contre le cancer vous pouvez faire
un don à l'association via le lia le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le point à présent sur l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 dans les yvelines au dernier
point publié mardi
lundi soir par dont 466 personnes sont
décédées dans les hôpitaux du
département depuis le début de la crise
de victimes en plus en 24 heures 627
patients sont hospitalisés en raison du
virus sur le territoire 48 toujours
placé en réanimation
et puis c'est une donnée positive
reparti à la hausse celle du nombre de
guéry et 1765 personnes sont revenus à
leur domicile après une amélioration de
leur état de santé
s'informer sur son projet professionnel
grâce à la cité des métiers de saint
quentin en yvelines la structure a
rouvert ses portes partiellement au
public aujourd'hui et a dû se
réorganiser pour respecter les gestes
barrières et dans les prochaines
semaines elle va a proposé également un
programme d'ateliers en visioconférence
aurélie ans
après deux mois de fermeture la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
située à trappes vient de rouvrir
partiellement ses portes
gels hydro alcooliques ou encore vitre
en plastique ont été installés pour
accueillir de nouveau le public un
accueil seulement sur rendez vous
pendant le confinement la structure a dû
se réorganiser et a poursuivi ses
entretiens conseils par téléphone dans
la première période le public jeune
puisque on était encore dans la période
parcours sud qui n'avait plus d'endroit
où aller pour se faire aider
les cio et les et les bureaux les bij
bureau information jeunesse étant
fermées sont revenus vers la cité des
métiers et ensuite le gros des demandes
c'était vraiment sur l'emploi et sur des
projets de reconversion et ensuite des
demandes dead sur la création
d'entreprise au total plus de 50
entretiens ont été réalisés afin de
poursuivre sa mission d'information sur
les projets professionnels la cité des
métiers va mettre en place des ateliers
ou visioconférence une vingtaine de
partenaires a répondu présent l'idée
c'était de voir
de maintenir ce lien avec les
partenaires et de voir ce qu'on pouvait
mettre en place pendant cette période
spéciale quand même comme atelier comme
on me conseille à distance de cette
réunion dont qui on a eu pas mal de
partenaires de cette réunion en est
sortie une programmation qui remplace la
programmation qu'on avait prévu jusque
jusqu'en juillet donc là on a une
nouvelle programmation d'ateliers
collectifs à distance à partir du 2 juin
plus de 25 ateliers sont proposés au
public autour de plusieurs thématiques
création d'activités bilan de
compétences ou encore savoir comment
gérer son stress
la présidente de la région ile de france
l'a confirmé hier le site de
remboursement du passe navigo ouvrira à
demain mercredi 3 millions d'abonnés
mensuels et annuels pourront s'y rendre
pour demander les dédommagements sur la
période d'avril et de début mai le site
qui sera accessible via l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et qui sera
accessible pendant plusieurs semaines
toujours en rapport avec les transports
l'institut vd comme implanté sur le
plateau de satory à versailles compte
depuis le 1er avril un nouveau président
antony jo a remplacé rémy bastien à ce
poste pour une durée de trois ans
renouvelable connie joe qui est avec
nous bonsoir bonsoir attirait alors
comment avez vous vécu déjà votre prise
de fonction le 1er avril dans ce
contexte forcément particulier
oui c'est un petit peu compliqué
heureusement on avait bien préparé avec
rémy dans les périodes pré- confinement
les échanges pour pouvoir m'assurer
cette continuité présidence évidemment
la difficulté assez pouvoir rencontrer
les gens c'est de pouvoir les connaître
ce qui est l'imitation à la vitesse à
laquelle je peux prendre mes fonctions
correctement on va dire alors du nord
pour vous présenter vous êtes diplômé de
supelec vous exercer dans le monde de
l'automobile depuis plusieurs années
vice président en charge de la r&d chez
psa vous êtes également le responsable
du véhicule connecté à la pf à la
plateforme automobile
comment abordez vous cette nouvelle
mission dans quel état d'esprit
l'abordez-vous écoutez j'ai toujours
rêvé faire de la recherche
ce que je n'ai jamais réussi à faire ou
pas je verrai réaction à
mon environnement à ce que je faisais à
ce que j'ai souhaité faire un instant t
donc là j'ai cette opportunité de
participer à une grande aventure et
franchement avec tout ce que j'ai pu
voir depuis que j'ai commencé c'est une
grande aventure on a beaucoup de choses
à faire mais justement l'expérience à
grèce va vous permettre de mener à bien
cette aventure de mener deux des projets
ou à la tête de dd com
alors en effet la particularité de vider
comme celle la confluence entre le monde
de l'industrie et le monde de
l'université de la recherche
universitaire elle donc mon expérience
professionnelle sur ce sujet va être
très important oui on rappelle que vd
comme et est implantée à versailles
l'institut regroupe 58 acteurs des
mobilités innovantes et durables
électrification véhicules autonomes
nouvelle solution de déplacement
réfléchir aux mobilité de demain
justement est ce que ça prend tout son
sens aussi aujourd'hui dans le contexte
actuel où revient sans cesse cette
thématique des transports notamment avec
ceux des confinement qui a commencé
encore plus que jamais parce que on voit
bien qu'on a on a besoin de prouver des
deux nouvelles solutions de mobilité
pour ne pas retomber dans dans l'est
dans les embouteillages monstres ou les
problèmes monstre que nous avons connues
de pollution avec l'automobile
omniprésente
donc on a besoin de pouvoir faire la
part des choses entre des nouvelles
sélections mobilité que ce soit de
l'autopartage que ce soit des navettes
autonome que ce soit d'électrification
de l'intégration des véhicules dans une
ville intelligente
il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
sujets à traiter la mobilité de demain
le véhicule de demain à quels enjeux
justement doit-il répondre à quels
objectifs
alors il de répondre en particulier en
première en première instance un
objectif de sécurité
ça c'est obligatoire on doit toujours
s'assurer de préserver la sécurité des
gens qu'ils transportent et de son
environnement
il doit répondre aux problèmes de
l'environnement limiter les émissions de
co2 donc être un véhicule électrique il
doit avoir la possibilité de redonner du
temps aux personnes qu'ils conduisent
avec la possibilité d'avoir cette
autonomie est également en cette
autonomie améliorant la sécurité du
transport
et puis il doit répondre à des besoins
de l'évolution du goût des gens les
jeunes aujourd'hui sont beaucoup moins
attirés par passer leur permis de
conduire qu'il ne l'était il ya 20 30 ou
40 ans il ya d'autres solutions qui
s'offrent à eux et qu'ils préfèrent et
le véhicule de demain justement être au
coeur des nombreux projets qui sont
menés par l'institut bd comme vous
confirmer il ya un foisonnement de
projets en ce moment aussi sur le
plateau de satory à versailles
absolument dans mon travail dans tous
les domaines que josé citer que ce soit
sur l'amélioration de 2,2 du coût de
possession d'un véhicule électrique
l'amélioration de son autonomie qui sont
vraiment des sujets clés pour pouvoir le
avoir le répandre le plus largement
possible
on travaille sur l'autonomie
l'amélioration de l'autonomie des
véhicules
comment utiliser l'infrastructure
routière pour améliorer l'intégration
des véhicules autonome dans dans la
route vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
sujets qui faisaient le congo dit et
donc vous êtes président point un mandat
de trois ans qui est renouvelable
les grands objectifs les grandes pistes
de ses premières 3 3 premières années à
quelles sont elles
justement alors effectivement cette
amende à trois ans renouvelable pourquoi
pas les premières listes sont axées sur
vraiment pousser quelques grands projets
qui sont très importants pour la
mobilité en france par exemple la
confluence entre la filière électronique
de puissance et la filière automobile
pour pouvoir faire un champion français
ou européen capable de rivaliser avec
les meilleurs les meilleurs asiatiques
ça c'est fondamental pour nos véhicules
électriques travailler justement sur la
répartition de l'intelligence entre le
véhicule autonome lui même et son
infrastructure savoir où il est plus
important d'avoir de l'intelligence pour
améliorer sa performance développer
l'humain au sein de du véhicule il est
très important de savoir comment se
comportent les humains quelles sont ses
attentes par rapport à ces nouvelles
solutions de mobilité
lenaria station quels sont les premiers
dossiers qui vous occupe actuellement
alors je travaille sur plusieurs
dossiers en coopération également être
la paix enfin vous avez si tout à
l'heure la filière automobile française
donc un projet de déploiement de
deux circuits tests sur la 5g en région
parisienne très important la 5g
fondamental pour pouvoir garantir la
communication de nos véhicules et
l'intégration de nos véhicules dans le
réseau un projet de d'homologation de
logiciels d'intelligence artificielle de
nos véhicules autonome pour s'assurer de
la sécurité des solutions qui sont
retenus et puis ce projet d'électronique
de puissance dont je vous ai un tout
petit peu parlé tout à l'heure qui est
quelque chose vraiment qu'on est en
train de mettre en place et je précise
que vd comme à d'ailleurs lancé une
grande étude sur le comportement et les
attentes des français en matière de
transport une consultation qui est
ouverte jusqu'au 25 mai vous pouvez vous
rendre pour répondre à cette
consultation sur le site qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci tony jo d'avoir
été avec nous merci beaucoup
tout nouveau président devait d comme
l'institut des mobilités innovantes
implantée à versailles il s'agit aussi
d'un transport de demain à l'horizon
2030 la ligne 18 doit relier l'aéroport
d'orly à versailles en passant par le
plateau de saclay et saint quentin en
yvelines le tout en une quarantaine de
minutes elle la société du grand paris
vient d'attribuer le premier marché de
génie civil de la ligne 18 vinci
construction spie batignolles dodin
campenon bernard et pas de fondations
seront en charge de la réalisation de
tunnels en gare d'antony massy opéra
massy palaiseau et l'aéroport d'orly
11,8 km à creuser au total pour un
marché de près de 800 millions d'euros
elles sont en grande souffrance depuis
la fin du confinement les salles de
sport devrait perdre entre 30 et 50% de
leur chiffre d'affaires cette année
témoignage dans un complexe installé à
guyancourt et qui compte plus de 1000
inscrits les détails de michael et demi
d'euros des appareils de musculation au
repos forcé depuis le 15 mars dernier
les 1000 clients de cette salle de sport
de guyancourt ne peuvent pas venir
transpirer à cause de l'épidémie de
couronnes un virus une situation
compliquée à gérer financièrement pour
les responsables ces derniers doivent
notamment rembourser certains clients
ont leur proposer des offres
on estime aujourd'hui la profession
avoir perdu entre 30 et 50% du chiffre
d'affaires sur l'année 2020 ce qui est
une perte assez colossal de plus on n'a
pas de visibilité comme je vous le dis
donc pas de l'information à donner à nos
adhérents parce qu'on peut pas les les
informer sur la date éventuelle
d'ouverture cette pause a également des
conséquences sur le matériel ces
machines sont d'ordinaire utilisé des
dizaines de fois par jour
ça nécessite de l'entretien qu'il faut
continuer à les faire fonctionner à voir
si tout est opérationnel pour la
réouverture aussi c'est important les
lubrifié vraiment réparer les petites
les petites choses entre guillemets la
bonne nouvelle c'est que voilà on n'a
plus le temps de se plonger vraiment de
plus en détail sur chaque machine pour
continuer à créer du lien avec les
adhérents pendant cette période la seule
a décidé de muscler sa stratégie en
mettant en place des cours sur internet
mais également des cours en extérieur du
pilote déconfinement depuis le 11 mai vu
que le gouvernement a réautorisé des la
pratique sportive à l'extérieur maximum
10 personnes on a effectivement ouvert
des cours collectifs limité donc à neuf
adhérents plus le coach et avec bien
entendu la distance en social du gel
hydroalcoolique à disposition la
désinfection du matériel
après et avant utilisation les gérants
espèrent désormais une réouverture pour
le 2 juin prochain pour retrouver un
second souffle
direction le château de dampierre en
yvelines pour refermer ce journal la
préfecture a autorisé le domaine à
accueillir de nouveaux du public une
reprise qui se fera le 30 mai le temps
de tout bien préparés marylène ya petit
cheminot et mélanie poker c'est une
double préparation que doit accomplir le
domaine de dampierre en yvelines avant
sa réouverture
le château a entamé sa rénovation juste
avant le confinement les travaux ont
repris au lendemain du lundi de pâques
avec le montage de cette impressionnante
échafaudage 50 compagnons s'attelle à
bien sécuriser le chantier à voir
l'accueil du public dans les jardins
c'était chevaux d'âge ne restera pas
comme ça derrière il faut que
l'échafaudage est achevée il reste plus
que la façade orientale a terminé et
bien on aura un parapluie qui va
protéger le temps de refaire la
couverture et ensuite il ya une bâche et
j'invite tout le monde à découvrir la
bâche parce que ça va être un petit clin
d'oeil à l'histoire de dampierre et donc
cette base a ceinturé et ensuite eh bien
il faut travailler sur les charpentes et
couvertures les enduits les fenêtres on
estime à environ 36 mois le temps à
consacrer pour la restauration du logis
faire du château
ça y est dl de part et d'autre de la
cour aux chantiers s'ajoute le nouveau
protocole sanitaire qu'il a fallu mettre
en place marquage au sol pour respecter
les distances en cas de files d'attentes
sens de circulation pour empêcher les
croisements installations de plexiglas
ok c'est au nouveau salon de thé dont la
terrasse qui avait été installé va
disparaître même les activités proposées
sont repensés on nous a interdit les
gaules fait on nous a interdit les
rosalies et les barques mais par contre
la golf les l'attelage tirée par les
mules américaine est maintenu et donc du
coup on met que la moitié des personnes
ont en fait on applique le protocole des
transports en bus des transports publics
dans un transport privé une ouverture de
saison retardé mais avec une grande
nouveauté des plans d'un jardin
pittoresque ont été retrouvés dans le
château les vestiges du jardin du
bosquet des chimères ont été restaurés
une balade de 1.5 km est proposé au
public avec des panneaux explicatifs de
son histoire pour les plus aventuriers
un jeu d'énigmes à résoudre pour
retrouver le jardinier disparu la veille
de la visite du roi en juin 1748 avec
plusieurs étapes dont la première le
labyrinthe restituer en clôture de
châtaignier récit salhab ira plus loin
c'est une grotte
il ya des endroits où il y avait des
cascades et on explique voilà que les
cascades ont disparu mais on est à
l'endroit où il y avait des cascades
donc à chaque fois on a essayé de faire
des points d'attraction pour faire
découvrir l'histoire de ce jardin
complètement oublié complètement effacés
d'ailleurs sur le terrain à l'exception
des vestiges comme ça ouverture le 30
mai pour profiter du parc du château de
dampierre
les visiteurs sont attendus avec
impatience et l'équipe réfléchit déjà
aux nouvelles activités pour la saison
2011 21 comme un échafaudage consacrée à
l'accueil du public pour suivre les
travaux de ce chantier si particulier
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité et très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]